Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an episode called “ADHD is Necessary”
from a Sci-fi drama anthology “On Children.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
In the future, the government wants only genius
citizens to live in their country. For this,
they implant an embryo in all women. The mothers
are given the responsibility to raise the children
to become an A-grade student. If a child gets good
grades, he and his mother are given an apartment
in an exclusive complex. Such mothers are also
awarded a glowing pin for their contribution to
society. The ones who do not get good grades
have to live in slums called the pigeon cage.
At the beginning of the movie, a mother is being
implanted with a new embryo. After the process,
she is handed a guidebook on how to raise the
embryo. She is asked to follow the guidelines
properly. Yang Chuan is the top mother who
has raised the best student they have ever had
named Ruo-Jie. Unfortunately, he was killed
in an accident some years ago. Following that,
she was implanted with a second embryo and
gave birth to Nova. Currently, she is in
a ceremony being awarded for her book on how a
mother can help their children get good grades.
Chuan is considered the best mother by many.
A woman in the audience asks her the secret
to raising A-grade children. The question
takes Chuan by surprise so she remains quiet.
The presenter claims that the question is
personal so she wouldn’t have to answer it.
It is clear that Chuan is hiding something.
Somewhere else, the higher officials of the
state are discussing the surge in the number of
narcoleptic children. Such children are taken to
the advancement programs and killed by the state,
declaring them as faulty embryos. Researcher Yi
Xian notices that all the students suffering
from sleep disorders have scored less than the
minimum standard. He puts two and two together
and finds out that the students who score low
are being falsely diagnosed, so the state could
get rid of them. When he confronts his superiors
about the matter, they falsely accuse him of
running an underground rebellious organization
against the state. He is soon arrested. Chuan is
with her daughter walking to their apartment after
the program. Alongside them, the students with low
scores and their mothers are being taken somewhere
by the guards. Suddenly, a woman comes running to
them, yelling that the students will be killed.
They panic and refuse to go with the guards. As
the crowd gets bigger, they start to run away
creating chaos. Amidst it, Chuan’s scarf falls to
the floor. After the commotion ends, Nova offers
to wash the scarf on her way to the bathroom. The
researcher Yi xian’s mother, Ling-Na recognizes
Nova as Chuan’s daughter. She seems to know
something about Chuan but doesn’t reveal it to
the girl. She simply hands her a keychain and says
that it is a gift from her late older brother.
A confused Nova returns to her mother and
finds her watching the news on a big screen.
It says that Yi Xian was going against the state
and its system so he was executed. His mother has
also been removed from the list of top mothers
because of his deeds. Nova recognizes the woman
as the person who gave her the keyring. However,
she doesn’t tell her mother about the encounter.
At home, Nova’s tutor teaches her about the first
cloning process for her upcoming exams. Nova
is not as diligent as her older brother, which
worries Chuan. She wants her daughter to score A+
at any cost because if she doesn’t they
will have to give up all their privileges.
Moreover, she is considered the best mother
in the city, so her daughter not getting good
grades is humiliating for her. After the
class, the tutor frankly tells her that he
thinks Nova will not pass the next test since her
grades have been falling every year. One of the
lights in Chuan’s “top mother pin” goes out. She
thinks that it is because of a technical problem
but the teacher explains that the lights go off
when one’s kid doesn’t perform well. Since Chuan’s
children had always had the best grades till
now, she didn’t know about the feature. The light
embarrasses her so she wears a scarf to hide it.
Following her meeting with the tutor, she brings
Nova to the pigeon cage where all the people
with low grades live. She wants her daughter
to get a taste of the life she will have if she
isn’t good at studies. In her heart, Chuan knows
that she doesn’t care about her child, she is
only worried about the humiliation she will face
if she has to leave the apartment complex. The
following day, Chuan has to go grocery shopping.
Embarrassed by her pin, she tries to put it down
but it blares an alarm telling her that she should
wear it everywhere she goes. She efficiently
hides it with a scarf and goes to the store
but a woman sees it nonetheless. She asks Chuan if
her daughter is getting good grades. Chuan openly
lies and says that Nova is doing better than ever.
On returning home, she witnesses a woman getting
kicked out of the apartment complex because of her
son’s grade. She blames her son for not being good
enough. The woman had been living in luxury for
the past fifteen years, and now she has to make
a life in the slums. Chuan holds her pin tightly,
seeing that she could go through the same thing in
the future. Later, she monitors Nova giving a test
through her tablet. Nova is visibly struggling to
answer questions which worries Chuan even more.
Soon, the second light in her pin also goes off.
Now, she has only three lights to go before
she has to leave the apartment and give up her
privileges. The next day at school, Nova acts
strange. She keeps on fidgeting with her pen
and books. When the person behind her asks
her to not move so much, she lashes out at
him. Even when the teacher asks her to not
be rude, she tells him his class is boring.
Everyone is surprised at her behavior because she
is usually very gentle and nice. The next day,
Chuan brings her to the hospital to get her
checked. She is diagnosed with ADHD. The
doctor claims that the stress of exams might have
been the cause of the disorder. He warns Chuan
to take good care of her daughter because if the
syndrome gets worse, she might go into depression.
The next day at school, Nova accidentally hits
her teacher on the leg while sweeping the floor.
She doesn’t apologize for her mistake and instead,
tells him he should watch where he is going. The
conversation escalates quickly and the teacher
holds her arm asking her to apologize. Nova runs
away and threatens to jump off the building. She
is stopped by her classmate Qi Zheng at last.
Chuan simply brings her home and serves her
dinner. It is then revealed that Chuan has asked
Nova to pretend to have ADHD so they can use it as
an excuse to avoid the upcoming exams. Chuan says
she is proud of her for her believable acting. The
next day is Nova’s birthday. Chuan wants her to
destroy all the presents that her classmates give
her. Nova is reluctant because she doesn’t want to
hurt her friends but Chuan persuades her to bring
a razor to school. At school, Nova’s friends wish
her a happy birthday. She knows what she has to do
but she cannot bring herself to hurt them. Chuan
watches her on a laptop as she puts the razor away
and gently opens her presents. Following that,
Qi Zheng and Nova talk about her weird behavior
yesterday. She claims that she was just nervous
because of the test. Qi Zheng asks her
if she is being pressured by her mother
but she claims that her mother is very
helpful, and she would never pressurize her.
On reaching home, Nova apologizes to her mother.
She doesn’t want to pretend to have ADHD anymore
and claims that she will study hard to get good
grades instead. Later at night, she shows her
mother the keyring that the strange woman had
given her in the bathroom. Chuan is shocked to
see it but doesn’t reveal its significance. She
simply asks her daughter to continue studying.
A flashback shows us that the keyring was handmade
by her late son Ruo-Jie as a birthday present for
her. But she asked him to stop making such
absurd things and focus on his studies. Back
in the present, Nova starts to study harder than
ever and stops pretending to have ADHD. One day,
she is again approached by the same old
woman, Ling-Na. She has found out about
Nova’s ADHD diagnosis and asks her if she really
has it or was it her mother’s plan. She reveals
that according to the guidebook, the students
with ADHD are considered defective embryos.
They are sent to an advancement program where they
are secretly killed. If a student gets bad grades,
both he and his mother are sent to the slums.
However, if the students have defects like ADHD,
they are sent to advancement programs and the
mothers can still enjoy their old privileges.
Chuan has been urging Nova to pretend because she
wants to keep her privileges even if it is at the
cost of her daughter’s life. Nova is in disbelief.
Furthermore, she is informed that her brother
Ruo-Jie’s death wasn’t an accident. She argues
that he was the best student nationwide so that
cannot be possible. Later that day, she reads the
article about Ruo-Jie’s death and finds out he was
hit by a truck. She then goes to meet the truck
driver who claims he was manipulated by her mother
to take the blame. Nova finally realizes that
her mother had to do something with his death.
The next day, she asks Qi Zheng if he knows about
the advancement program that kills people. He
asks her to be quiet because talking about it is
illegal. Qi Zheng lives in the slums, so he knows
everything about the state’s unfair program. Chuan
sees them talking through the surveillance cameras
and goes to meet Qi Zheng the next day. She asks
him to stay away from her daughter. But Qi Zheng’s
mother stands up for her son, claiming that he can
talk to whoever he wants. After finding out she
will soon be sent to the advancement program, Nova
runs away from home and goes to Qi Zheng’s house.
His mother brings her to a secret tunnel
that leads them to a camp of survivors of
the advancement program. It was established by
Ling-Na after her son’s execution. She believes
that every kid has something they are good at
and grades don't define their worth. Hence,
she has established this place to give those kids
an opportunity to do whatever they enjoy. Everyone
at the camp is nice to Nova but she feels like she
is betraying her mother by staying there. When no
one is looking, she leaves them a message and runs
away. In the message, she expresses her gratitude
to them and promises to not tell others about the
camp. When she reaches home, Chuan simply asks her
to eat her dinner. Nova apologizes for letting
her down and promises to study even harder.
She asks her mother if she loves her
but Chuan doesn’t answer her question.
Later, Nova is in the shower when she feels dizzy.
She falls to the ground and drags herself out.
When she opens her eyes, she finds herself in a
hospital bed. She is declared a faulty embryo and
sent to the advancement program to be executed. In
the following scene, we see Chuan being implanted
with another embryo. When she wakes up after the
transplant, she finds herself in the tunnel that
leads to the survivor camp. Ling-Na asks her if
she is happy after killing two of her children.
She claims that her third one will grow to be
the same. Chuan still doesn’t back down and
asserts that she has won this war. She returns
home and gets to keep the apartment along with
all her privileges. She even writes a book
about losing two children and profits off it.
A flashback shows us that Ruo-Jie wanted to be
a carpenter but Chuan didn’t support his dream.
He eventually got depressed which led to
his death. She also informs the police
about Ling-Na’s secret camp getting all of
the students arrested. In the end, she is in
an interview to promote her new book. She looks
into the camera and says that if you really want
something to happen, there is always a way.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like
to help the channel out. Thanks for watching.